No
matter how I look at it, I have a lot of eyes.
I want to do it I'm
strangely calm because of the candy situation
Is it really okay or is it impossible?
Hey,
I wonder if I can make a fish out of transparent land
That's difficult, isn't it
?  I get it, but it's not very efficient So let's make the heart bigger and thicken the result Let's
make it
last The leader himself takes in oxygen directly It's
ok It's okay  What's the point? But if you make eye contact in a big bath, it's really scary.
If you're a transparent angel, of
course, the reason I'm transparent is that the light that reaches my eyes passes through without being caught by my retinas
.
Joel is the true loneliness